if we look at this paranoid delusional
system stalin was in power for 30 years
he is
many argue one of the most powerful men
in history
did in his case absolute power corrupt
him or did it reveal the true nature of
the man and maybe just in in your sense
as we kind of build around this genocide
of the early 1930s
this paranoid delusional system did it
get built up over time was it always
there
it's it's kind of a question of um
did the genocide was that always
inevitable essentially in this man or
did power create that
mean it's a great question and i don't
think you can i i don't think you can
say that it was always uh in kind of
inherent in the man
i mean the man without his position
and without his power
you know wouldn't have been able to
accomplish what he eventually uh did in
the way of murdering people you know and
murdering groups of people which is what
genocide is
so you know i don't i ca it wasn't sort
of in him i mean they were and again you
know the new research has shown
that you know he had his childhood was
um you know not a particularly
nasty one and people used to say you
know the father beat
beat him up and it turns out actually it
wasn't the father was the mother once in
a while
but but basically you know he was not
an unusual young georgian
kid or student even
and it you know it was it was the the
growth of the soviet system and him
within the soviet system
i mean his own development within the
soviet system i think that led
you know to the kind of uh mass killing
that occurred in the 1930s
um
you know he essentially achieved
complete power by the early
1930s
and then as he
as he rolled with it as you would say
you know or people could say
you know it increasingly became
murderous
uh and there was no
um you know there were no checks and
balances obviously on that that
murderous system and not only that you
know people supported it
uh in the nkvd and elsewhere he learned
how to manipulate people i mean he was a
superb
you know political manipulator of of of
those people around him
and um
uh
you know we have we
we've got new transcripts for example of
you know police bureau meetings in the
early 1930s
and you read those things and you re you
know he uses humor and he uses
sarcasm especially he uses verbal ways
to undermine people you know to control
their behavior and what they do and he's
a really uh you know
he's a real
i guess manipulator is the right word
and he does it
he does it with um
you know a kind of skill
that on the one hand
is admirable and on the other hand of
course
is uh is terrible because it ends up you
know creating the system
uh of terror
that he creates
i mean i i guess just to linger on it
i just wonder how much of it is a
slippery slope
in the early
20s 1920s
did he think he was going to be
murdering even a single person but
uh thousands
and millions
i just wonder
maybe the murder of a single human being
just to get them
you know because you're paranoid about
them potentially threatening your power
does that murder and open a door and
once you open the door
you become a different human being a
deeper question here is the soldier
knits and
you know the line between good and evil
runs in every man are all of us once we
commit one murder in this situation does
that open a door for all of us
and it
i guess even the further deeper
questions how
how how easy it is for human nature to
go on the slippery slope that ends in
genocide
there are a lot of questions in those
in those questions and uh
you know the slippery soap question i
would i would answer i suppose by saying
you know stalin wasn't the most likely
uh successor of lenin there were plenty
of others
there was uh there were a lot of
political contingencies that emerged in
the 1920s
that
made it possible for stalin to seize
power i don't think of him as a
you know if you would just know him in
i don't think anybody would say much
less himself that this was a future mass
murderer i mean trotsky mistrusted him
and thought he was a you know um
a mindless bureaucrat
you know others were less mistrustful of
him
but you know he managed to gain power in
the way he did through this bureaucratic
and political maneuvering
uh that was very uh successful
you know the slippery slope as it were
doesn't really begin
until the 1930s in my view in other
words once once he gains complete power
in control of the police bureau
once the the the um
programs that he institutes of the
five-year plan and
collectivization go through
once he reverses himself and is able to
reverse himself or reverse the soviet
path you know to give
various nationalities their you know
their ability to develop their own
cultures and sort of
internal uh politics once he reverses
all that you know you have the ukrainian
famine in 32 33 you have the murder
of kirov who is one of the leading
figures you know in the political system
you have the suicide of his wife you
have all these things come together in
that then
you know
make it more likely
in other words that bad things are going
to happen
and people start seeing that too around
him they start seeing that it's not a
slippery slope it's a it's a dangerous
it's a dangerous uh
situation which is emerging
and and some people really understand
that so i don't i i really do see a
differentiation then between the 20s i
mean it's true that stalin during the
civil war there's a lot of you know good
research on that
um you know shows that he already had
some of these characteristics of being
as it were murderous and being
um you know being um
dictatorial and pushing people around
and that sort of thing that was all
there
but i don't i don't really see that as
kind of the necessary stage for the next
thing that came well which was the 30s
which was really
terror
of the worst sort you know where
everybody is afraid for their lives and
their most people are afraid for their
lives and their families lives and where
torture and that sort of thing becomes a
common part
you know of who who what people had to
face so it's a different
it's a different world and you know
people will argue they'll argue this
kind of lenin
stalin
continuity debate you know that's been
going on since i was an undergraduate
right that that argument you know was
stalin the natural sort of next step
from lenin or was he something
completely different
um
many people will argue you know because
of marxism leninism because the ideology
that you know is it was the next natural
it was a kind of natural next step i
don't think so you know i would i would
tend to lean the other way not
absolutely i mean i won't make an
absolute argument
that what stalin became had nothing to
do with lenin and nothing to do with
marxism feminism it had a lot to do with
it
but
you know he takes it one step one major
step further and again that's why i
don't like the slippery slope you know
metaphor because that means it's kind of
slow and easy it's a leap yeah and and
we call you know i mean historians talk
about the stalin revolution
you know in 28 and 29 you know that he
he in some senses
creates a whole new system you know
through the five-year plan
collectivization and seizing political
power the way he does
you